[Applause]
as dick mentioned it was here at
Berkeley that I first started working on
the theory of randomness and pseudo
randomness and I am really happy to see
that in the audience are some of the
teachers who taught me the subject and
some of the collaborators who with whom
I've I've worked on the subject and I'm
sure grin to see that and other people
in the audience weren't even born at the
time um anyway um the the other kind of
general comment I want to make is that
if you like this talk then you'll love
IV wid Gerson's talk that has pretty
much a better version of this talk and
it's coming up very soon next week
avi what's what's the exact date it's
not here it's downtown the 22nd ok
something like the 22nd okay and the
last general comment I want to make is
I'm sort of like turning conventional
wisdom on its head I am mainly citing
people you know at length who are not
here in the sitting in the audience and
ignoring the relevant citations for
people in the audience so and mainly
because you know the people I'm gonna
like cite aren't to get it isn't to give
them credit is to do honor to our field
by claiming them as ancestors okay so
okay so all right I'm gonna talk about
does randomness solve problems and you
know every time people see this the
title of this talk they've been asking
well do it does random it solve problems
so I'm just gonna give you the answer
first you can skip the rest of the talk
if you want because all of it is
explaining this answer yes randomness
solves problems but you probably don't
need randomness to be random to in order
to to solve the problems you just need
you just you can have deterministic
randomness and it will solve the
problems anyway and you know probably
most random ways you come up with of
generating deterministic randomness a
lot of them work but but not all of them
and and then it's certainly true though
you know even that randomness solves
like random instances randomness doesn't
need to be random to in order to solve
random instances of problems okay so
that's that's the whole talk if you if
you got the the bits that you want you
can leave now
okay so first I want to say when I think
about problems I'm not talking about all
problems out there in the world there
are actually lots of areas where
randomness can prove ly solve problems
like in cryptography you provably need
randomness in game theory you provably
need randomness in distributed systems
you provably need randoms so I'm just
going to talk about a particular kind of
problem I mean computational problem and
solving means having a faster algorithm
now you can also discuss the same
similar problems with other kind of
resources such as memory it's
interesting I didn't have time to even
start it okay so so by a problem we mean
a computational problem it a
computational problem
it doesn't solve the problem of
displaying things on the slide so a
computational problem has an input and
we view the input as a discrete can be
represented discreetly and finitely as a
sequence of bits it has some kind of
output this also can be represented
discreetly and finitely as a sequence of
bits and it has some kind of
relationship that's that's that's going
to that should hold between the output
and the input okay so that's what I mean
by a problem and note that a problem is
always has like infinitely many
instances each input is a different
instance of the problem and now an
algorithm is a general procedure that
goes through a sequence of fixed
computational steps finite istic steps
and produces from the input and output
that hopefully actually has the
relationship that that satisfies
correctness and we're interested in the
number of steps so when I ask does
randomness solve problems
I mean if we've got a if we add to our
instruction set besides the standard
like addition multiplication boolean
operations and so on the ability to in
one step
flip a totally random coin so pick a
value B at random equally likely to be 0
and 1 does that change the power of the
model does that allow significantly
faster algorithms for problems for
computational problems and a
computational problem in the sense that
I just defined ok so um now when we talk
about the redness of the algorithm if
the algorithm is going through a number
of adaptive steps to flip random coins
you could front-load that process if you
know how many abound on how many times
the algorithm is going to perform that
operation you can flip all the coins in
advance and view that
the random input to your algorithm the
results of those t coin flips as the
random input to your algorithm and then
you you view the randomized algorithm as
a deterministic algorithm on the real
input and the randomized input so when
we're talking about whether the
randomness of the algorithm needs to be
random we're talking about whether this
really needs to be uniformly distributed
this variable here okay so now when
would we say that randomness really
solves a problem we would say that
randomness is like essential to solve a
problem in the worst case if there's a
problem and a randomized algorithm that
and we wouldn't want a randomized
algorithm just has like an
infinitesimally better than then 1/2
chance of guessing the right answer we
want an algorithm that reliably gets the
right answer so it's reliably correct
correct with high probability and it's
much faster on large inputs than any
deterministic algorithm for the same
problem okay so we formalize the class
of problems that have efficient
randomized algorithms as the class bpp
of problem solvable and randomized
polynomial time and even though we sort
of like you always use polynomial as our
canonical time you can just think of
this as fast
okay so polynomial has nice closure
properties but really everything we're
talking about can be can be totally made
general if you allow in arbitrary kind
amount of time and then we're comparing
that to P the class of problems that can
be solved deterministically in
polynomial time okay so we're asking its
randomness helps in the worst case if B
P P is a strict superset of P and it
doesn't help if B P P equals P
and the doesn't help in every instance
of the problem but we could also ask and
we're going to be looking at algorithms
that are probabilistic algorithms but
they're not guaranteed to have high
success on every instance of the problem
we call the but they might have a lot of
you know might have high success on many
interesting instances of the problem so
we call an algorithm that solves the
many instances or the problem on a
subset of instances a promise bpp
problem if it's a pono mealtime
probabilistic algorithm but it solves it
on some class of instances and so we
could similarly ask whether promised VPP
is a strict superset of promise p so
does to say that that that is saying
that there always there are some
instances of some problems that where
randomness is essential okay as opposed
to the other there are some problems
where on even in the worst case
randomness is essential okay so so if
promise be p p equals promise P then P
equals B P P but if not known to hold in
the other direction okay so so we'd be
talking about both of both of these at
least implicitly so why would anyone
think that flipping random bits would
actually help speed computation you know
cuz like doing something random you
seems like you should do something
that's better than random you know cuz
you like if you do it put a zero you're
doing one thing you flip with one you're
doing the other thing well why don't you
just do the better of those two things
so the first at least the first recorded
person who had this idea
of using randomness to solve problems
with Stanislaw ulam it is really
remarkable because this idea of using
randomness to solve to speed up
algorithms came up sort of
simultaneously with the idea of using
computers at all
so this this is the person the the the
thing he's holding in his hand is like a
model of one of the first this was
actually an analog computer that they
used in the Manhattan Project and Sana's
Illume was a researcher in the in the
Manhattan Project so they hadn't really
like quite developed the computer but
they were still looking at faster out
computer pastor computer algorithms okay
and this idea of randomness came up and
here's how it it seems to have come up
now my historical research is all like
looking things up on Wikipedia
so take it with whatever grains of salt
to you you want one to give but it seems
the story is that Salem had to have a
surgery and after the surgery he was at
the hospital for a few weeks you know
with not a lot to do so he did what a
lot of people do when they don't have a
lot to do he played solitaire to pass
the time and he played a kind of
complicated solitaire called Campfield
and this sort of has personal meaning to
me because there was a when I was a
postdoc in Toronto there was a
computerized Campfield program and I
wasted a lot of time playing camfil so
you know I have something in common with
Desilu them which makes me proud okay
anyway so it's a complicated it's a
complicated solitaire game it's not so
easy to know what the best strategy is
and so he was like trying to compute you
know what the odds of winning under
different strategies for for Campfield
were any first tried to do it master
matically and i think this is
particularly difficult because he was he
was like lying in bed not able to move
very much so he probably didn't even
have a pencil and paper so but he was
failing too he was failing to
mathematically analyze this game he said
well you know if I really want to know
the answer we have these you know
computational devices in the Manhattan
Project I could use one of those
computational devices to simulate
thousands of runs of Campfield
and actually compute the probability by
by random sampling this is sort of like
the the kind of thought you have when
you're under sedation but then he went
back I should say he went back to the
Manhattan Project and they needed to
simulate the behavior of atomic
particles you know to perform integrals
that involves you know countless paths
of collisions of events involving
collisions of different kinds of atomic
particles and sum them all up and they
needed a good approximation for the Sun
and he had said well here's the idea I
had about simulating Campfield we could
do the same thing probabilistically
simulate you know not every kind of
combination of events but simulate what
happens probabilistically and see and
thus get a good estimate of the
probability and so they actually did
this this was part of how we won World
War two okay through solitaire games
okay so um no his colleague Nicolas
metropolis I think was what trying to
make fun of him he and dubbed this the
Monte Carlo method okay
because metropolis had an uncle who
always went to the Monte Carlo and lost
his money gambling and so and so he felt
like
I don't know whether this was like a
slur or not I don't you know but the
name Monte Carlo method stuck okay so
you in like so one way of viewing the
Monte Carlo method in in generality is
you've got some kind of complicated
function you want to know the average
value of this function if you've got us
you know people do numerical integration
for smooth nice functions by sampling at
uniform points but a lot of functions
that come up in actual life and this is
like internet access behavior taken by
some we're from some random website but
you see this very this behavior in real
life is often very bursty and so if you
do this regular sampling you may miss
peak peak peak values and get a very
very bad estimate but if you sample at
random places it doesn't matter what the
function looks like you don't have to
understand the function you'll get a
statistically valid with high
probability estimate with relatively few
samples no matter what the function
looks like so you don't have to know
what bounds on the derivative you don't
have to know any kind of continuity so
so there's a discrete version of this
problem where you're trying to evaluate
the average of a function and it can be
arbitrarily messy and that's the the
circuit approximate probability problem
so the circuit a boolean circuit is a
boolean operation it's just a inputs to
0 1 bits and outputs another another pit
and there's just a finite number of them
like and or not and you can build up
others from those ok and so a boolean
circuit is
step-by-step procedure where every step
is just one of these boolean operations
on to previously computed computed
elements so when we do computation on
any kind of computational device it
eventually gets translated into this
kind of boolean algebra it goes you know
might go from the CPU you know
eventually all the actual computation
steps happen on the CPU the CPU is just
a combination of these logic gates and
so every step of a any complicated
algorithm can be broken down into these
boolean circuit operations into these
boolean operations and so the circuit
model can code any kind of elaborate
computation the only kind of constraint
on it is that we usually think of
algorithms as uniform have to apply the
inputs of arbitrary lengths the circuit
model is non-uniform in that every input
size it only applies each circuit only
applies to a fixed number of boolean
inputs okay and so you have to look at
what happens you know when you have
circuits for different sizes of input
I'm sort of stressing these points not
because there's that relevant to this
particular example but because it's
going to come back later okay so so the
circuit approximate probability
probability problem is to you're given a
boolean circuit and you want to know if
you pick the inputs to the boolean
circuit at random you want to estimate
the probability it's a circuit outputs
one okay so clearly you can do this in
probably with a probabilistic algorithm
you pick random inputs and you see what
the probability is that the circuit
outputs one and you keep on doing this
till you have a very good estimate with
high probability here good estimate
means small additive error to within 0.1
additively
say the exact number doesn't really
change the problem but if we could solve
this problem deterministically this is
what's called a complete problem for the
class promise bpp that we mentioned
earlier and so solving this problem
being able to terminus tically simulate
this kind of Monte Carlo estimation
would in fact show that these that
randomness never helps even on some
instances for the solving problems
significantly faster yes
you might be able to you can derive one
by like so in some sense there's an
analytic solution to this problem you
could write it down as this big integral
you can write down boolean operator
interpolate boolean operations by
arithmetic opera arithmetic operations
and then you can actually like integrate
over a big high dimensional cube and
that's in some sense an analytic
solution but if you translate that to an
algorithm you actually get an
exponential time algorithm it was really
saying is it's hard to do really
complicated integrals in high
dimensional spaces not that it's easy to
solve this problem does that answer your
question
you know so so if you just have it if
you just have like a finite number a
fixed number you can do that but once
you start taking an end and feeding it
into an or and it rapidly becomes much
much less clear what's going on yeah oh
right but if you so baby the example I
gave was bad in that I well I think how
you at least reused a variable but yes
so the tricky part is when you you read
the read ones case is not the hard case
so so another probabilistic algorithm
that's almost as as oh well you know
five or six years younger is also named
after this metropolis who named Monte
Carlo algorithms the story is that so
they were there's a five author paper
and metropolis is the first author what
I've heard the the four other is
interesting the the four other authors
were two married couples which is pretty
rare still to have a paper with not just
one married couple but two and and I'm
told that those four actually did all
the the interesting algorithm design and
that one metropolis did was give them
permission to run their algorithm on his
computer but I'm not sure whether that's
completely fair but and but it's also
not completely fair that ever since it's
been called the metropolis algorithm
sometimes metropolis hasty another
reason so now the metropolis algorithm
solves a different kind of problem is is
it's not trying okay so it's used in a
number of different situations so first
I should say you could use it for
sampling and there is kind of fairly
well understood for sampling and its
original kind of motivation was for bio
sampling but but as it in its variants
are most frequently used now as search
in optimization heuristics where you're
trying to find the you know the typical
np-complete problem you have a huge
number of possible solutions and you're
trying to find the best one according to
some mathematical function
okay so so metropolis and its variants
like simulated annealing go with the
winners genetic algorithms and crawling
algorithms
Tabu search and on and on and on all are
sort of like start with this metropolis
idea and put in put in refinements and
there used to come up with probabilistic
algorithms randomized algorithms that
aren't guaranteed to work on every case
but seem to work on many instances of
the problem this is a definitely going
to be like the in the promised bpp world
rather than the BPP world okay and the
reason why you want some randomness is
if you just sort of like do
deterministic behavior in optimization
and you're just trying to like find
making like small tweaks to the current
solution then you tend to get stuck in
what are known as local optima these are
solutions where there's no no way small
change to the solution that makes them
better but they're not global Optima if
you make a big change to this solution
you can do much better okay so um what
the metropolis algorithm does is balance
greedy descent with randomness that
allows you to to even if you're
currently at a local minima you have
some probability of going to states that
are that are going uphill
rather than downhill even when you're
trying to minimize okay so so I'm not
going to give the details of the
algorithm but a lot of these different
optimization heuristics use this idea of
using randomness to balance greedy
behavior with random behavior in
to avoid getting stuck at these local
minima and eventually finding the global
minimum should say yes you know even the
the basic metropolis algorithm when you
use it in that context it is not well
understood so it's we still it was like
one of the first randomized algorithm
suggested and we still are very we're
still in baby in the embassy of
even understand is that it's a
relatively simple algorithm and we still
are barely at the beginning of
understanding and it works really well
on many instances and we still don't
know why okay okay so then this this
both of the algorithms I randomized
types of algorithms that I've talked
about so far were discovered in the 40s
and 50s much later in the 70s a kind of
new interesting use of randomized
algorithms was discovered in in
basically number theory and algebraic
problems okay
in the like the the biggest success
story at the time was prime ality
testing it's a really basic mathematical
problem given an integer can you factor
it into two is a product of two two
smaller integers or is it a prime number
and in the interesting thing is that
prime allottee testing you know the
obvious approach is to try to factor the
number but factoring the factoring
numbers seems to be much much more
difficult than deciding whether than the
number has a factor okay and and one
reason is that there's this kind of
equation that I got wrong
is that if you take any number mod any
integer you've raised it to a prime
minus one and take the remainder mod P
you get one if you if I put the P here
if I didn't put the minus one then the
rest would be incorrect okay
oh and this with the minus
so maybe I should just blank this minus
one that's actually makes it simpler
okay
so so so another so this holds for any
prime so if you find an X where it
doesn't hold then you know that P is not
prime and so a lot of the algorithms are
based on finding and X where Fermat's
Last Theorem little theorem doesn't hold
and thus concluding that the number is
composite without average actually
finding any of the factors now there
there's strange numbers called
Carmichael numbers that also satisfy
this equation but are not prime and that
creates difficulty both ignore that okay
so so so the way the story should have
gone is that a number of people
discovered that if you plug in random
values of X and P is not prime then you
find quickly find a counter example and
then Gary Miller discovered that if you
assume the extended Riemann hypothesis
those random numbers don't have to be
random you can just pick them in a small
interval and and is still going to find
one that doesn't
that's the counter example relatively
quickly if it's not prime and it's not a
Carmichael number so that's how the
story should have gone but like history
in general things worked though don't
work like they should have okay so
actually Garry Miller's result that if
the extended remind hypothesis is true
then prime ality testing can be done
deterministically came first
and then Michael Rabin and salivating
strossen independently observed that
this that if you drop the extended
remind hypothesis you could still
develop a randomized algorithm along the
same the same lines so by the way this I
love this picture of Bob solavei when I
was a student this is my imagining him
to looking looking like he did in the
when when this algorithm was discovered
when I was a student here he didn't
quite look like this but I took many
classes with Bob's all of a while I was
a student here and when I say took many
classes with him I took some classes
from him but he also sat in many of the
classes so he was a fellow student in
many of the theory of computer science
classes and the thing about him when he
was a student in the class he would
answer every question so it created a
lot of competition okay so okay so
flash-forward more than 20 years 25
years and Agrawal Kyle and sexina
showed how to deer an demise these
probabilistic randomized prime ality
testing so that had also been done
before the randomized algorithms existed
by Gary Miller as I said but assuming
some big open problems in mathematics so
these three gave a different randomized
algorithm and then used used techniques
similar to what Gary was talking about
to replace the randomness with
determinism except instead of assuming
big open problems in math
Mattox they had to actually use the fact
that some they had to actually prove it
themselves but also like use some
advances in in number theory okay so it
wasn't the same algorithm but they
managed to deer an demise a randomized
algorithm and come up with a
deterministic polynomial time algorithm
so this kind of you know phenomenon have
you come up with a randomized algorithm
and then you later come up with some
version of the algorithm where you place
the randomness with deterministic bits
and come up with a deterministic
algorithm happens quite frequently and
there's kind of this life cycle of
randomized algorithms they're introduced
as randomized and then and then they're
made deterministic sometimes that life
cycle takes you know 25 years other
times it happens in the paper that
introduces the randomized algorithm so
so but it's sort of like makes you
suspicious that these randomized
algorithms are just kind of a way of
thinking about the problem as a stepping
stone to a deterministic algorithm but
here's another randomized algorithm that
was introduced around the same time
again by a lot of people in parallel
swart simple and demillo and liftin and
this one has sort of survived the test
of time even better than the prime ality
algorithm we have still even though
we've Duran demised some special cases
we still have no idea how to Duran
demise it in general and I'm gonna talk
about maybe why a little bit later I
don't know how much later I have okay so
you're given an equation where both
sides are polynomials in a certain
number of they're in integer variables
and we think of this equation beginning
by an algebraic version of the circuit
model that I talked about earlier and
then you want to decide whether that
equation is true the randomized
algorithm is just a plug in random
valley
for the variables in a certain range but
then there's one other little tricky
part where you don't compute the value
explicitly you compute them mod a
relatively small number to keep them
from blowing up too big and I said this
problem is still wide open as far as D
randomization goes it's still like a
classical randomized algorithm that 30
years later hasn't been hasn't been too
randomized okay so on another kind of
general way randomness is used in
algorithms I call random self
reducibility of this may not be totally
appropriate but a lot of geometric
problems there are a lot easier if the
problems are far our in general position
and not close to and sort of
substantially far from anything that's
not in general position and so a lot of
the use of randomness is to say well if
you've got a worst case problem where
things are very close to being say in a
line but they're not in a line we want
two random I randomly tweaked it so that
no three points are close to being in a
line so we're mapping we're using
randomness to take the kind of a typical
worst case instance and map it into a
more typical average case instance
preserving the the relevant property so
so these are like like four classes of
randomized algorithms in depending on
which class you think are the most
important this this sort of like gives
your a priori intuition about whether
randomness really helps or not I think
so see you okay so here are like
different intuitions you might have you
might think randomness always helps
every problem I don't think that's a
reasonable view but it's a possible view
I'll call that the zealots view you
you're really into that randomness stuff
okay or if you use this last approach
where you're randomly tweaking
worst-case inputs to get
typical instances using randomness you
might think that randomness will help in
the worst case but a typical instance it
probably doesn't even quire randomness
so I'll call that the averaging view
okay well but if you use it as a
heuristic you might think it helps in
the average case but not in the worst
case so I'll call this the heuristic
view or if you're like a number theory
person you think well randomness is
helping when there's a lot of algebraic
structure to the problem and so it's
going to help for this kind of class of
problems a lot both in the average in
the worst case but but there'll be
problems where it doesn't help a lot so
I'll call that the structural view
structured for you okay or you could
just view think yeah brand-new this
probably doesn't really help it's
probably just a heuristic for thinking
about deterministic algorithms so I'll
call that the skeptical view okay so so
a lot of all these views are most of
these views are I think are reasonable
intuitions but we've actually ruled out
strong versions of some of them and it's
not the most extreme that we've rolled
out it's the middle that we've ruled out
okay so and I'm convinced kept tick
because I have some know some surprising
things that would happen if this kept
achill view is not true so let me try to
assist to explain why okay so um so
alright I kept on arguing that
randomized algorithms have been
important from the beginning but the sad
truth is that randomized algorithms have
never have hardly ever been run been
used as advertised
these randomized algorithms that were
done in the Manhattan Project we're
actually done with these very crude
pseudo-random generators based on
squaring numbers and taking the middle
bits because it was kind of hard to
produce good random bits when there are
other like disadvantages to actually
using random bits so so people always
use randomized algorithms not with
Random randomness but with pseudo
randomness and you can like exactly
brought created lots of trouble and in
fact Lucca Trevisan just sent me an
article where flawed pseudo randomness
is creating trouble
of course it's creating trouble for
people I don't really care about their
the operators of casinos who are using
bad pseudo-random generators in there
cuz slot machines and and because of
that they were starting to lose money
from people who mathematically analyze
the slot machine the pseudo randomness
and these slot machines and and started
finding called holes in it so I'm not
sure who to root for here in this story
but you can see that this is a danger of
using bad pseudo randomness so but what
is good pseudo randomness okay now I
think the first convincing definition of
good pseudo randomness was by Andy Yau
building on work earlier work of Shamir
Blum and McCauley okay so this is like a
taste test kind of analog the taste test
you know if you can't tell the
difference between butter and margarine
if you can fool mother nature then then
you know there's no reason to use one or
the one or the other okay
not to use the margarine okay so if you
because margarine is cheaper okay so if
you can't tell the difference between
the outputs of a pseudo-random generator
maybe using a very small seed and
producing a long pseudo-random string
and a truly random string if that's a
computationally hard problem then
there's no harm in using the cheaper
pseudo-random string as opposed to the
expensive random string and if you can
make that strong enough then you can do
exhaustive search over the seeds and
actually simulate the algorithm on the
pseudo-random randomness
deterministically ok so so how do we get
our hands on that on good on pseudo to
know to say this is an interesting thing
because now we're saying in order to
design an algorithm what we need is a
computationally hard problem a problem
that has no good algorithm it's kind of
counterintuitive from a hardness from a
lower bound we're getting an algorithm
and we're going to see actually there's
some if I if I don't run out of time
we're gonna see that there's actually
some results in the other direction as
well okay so so what does it mean like
to have a what kind of hardness do we
need so we're gonna use so hardness
verses the the class of circuits that we
talked about earlier having high circuit
complexity now we don't know we know as
an existence proof using a probabilistic
argument that there exists most
functions have very high circuit
complexity require almost exponential
size circuits I'm gonna go really fast
here ok so it's kind of come but we
don't have any explicit functions in low
complexity classes that we know require
high circuits so like up until last year
the best lower bound was just three n
and that was the same lower bound since
1984 last year there was a breakthrough
is now 3.01 times n and if we keep on
going this in a million years we'll have
foreign
so so so so it's a challenge to come up
with explicit problems that require
large circuits thank you
and this challenge in the challenge of
coming up with ways of D randomizing
algorithms turn out to be pretty much
two sides of the same coin and I want to
like explain that a little bit in the
almost zero time I have left okay so the
the starting point was this breakthrough
paper of the solder wick ursin that
showed how to convert suitably hard of
four circuits functions into
pseudo-random generators and with some
follow-up work the the punchline is that
if you've got a function that you can
compute in exponential time that
requires exponential size circuit size
then you can use it to construct a
pseudo-random generator that's so strong
that you can use it to completely team
analyze randomized algorithm not just in
the worst case one on every case every
instance instance by instance okay so
this says that if we've got such a lower
bound then the skeptic viewpoint is
completely right randomness doesn't need
to be random in order to be helpful we
can simulate randomness
deterministically okay and so if the
skeptic view point is wrong then this
kind of hardness doesn't exist but this
kind of hardness doesn't exist what
that's saying is for every hard problem
every exponential time problem I can
save time by working offline and develop
an algorithm that's tuned to a
particular input size that's just super
polynomial s then the time it takes to
solve the problem I think that's really
counterintuitive so that's why I'm a
sort of strong skeptic now that we know
these results
here's another here's another example of
a result that puts the that that helps
the skeptic viewpoint avi and I showed
that yeah unless X exponential time
equals be VP so this is the extreme
zealot position that randomness helps
not just in particular problems but
every problem everywhere you know every
hard problem you can solve with this
magic bullet of randomness so that's a
very unlikely event or the the other
conclusion is that it's sub exponential
time ideally it would be polynomial time
but we don't have that we can
deterministic you simulate any
randomized algorithm on the typical case
by typical cases it means that you
actually can't find you know it's a
computationally hard problem to find
instances where that simulation doesn't
work so there might be worse case
instances on which the simulation
doesn't work but you can't even you'll
never find them so they don't merely
matter so it says in some sense either
we have the extreme gsella position or
some mild skeptic position and there are
lots of caveats that I'm not mentioning
here okay
so this kind of rules out some of the
very plausible intuitions I think like
the heuristic position where you say
well does randomness helps in the
typical case but not in the worst case
that's actually just not true
if randomness helps in the in the
typical case it helps in every case okay
and it's just not true that randomness
help for some problems but not all
problems either it helps for all
problems or it can be eliminated on
average for all problems so so things
that seemed like really like the most
possible before you started thinking
about it before you started doing this
research are actually the position
I've been sort of ruled out in the
extreme positions randomness is useless
randomness is all-powerful those are the
ones that are left okay so in the minute
or two this remains I want to say that
there are actually some results in the
other direction I said this this connect
question of D randomization is linked to
circuit complexity we've talked about
using circuit lower bounds to do
randomized algorithms there are actually
results that go the other direction with
with Valentina and avi we showed that if
you could do randomized that circuit
approximation problem then you get a
lower bound not in X like what we we
needed to get the D randomization but in
just one class bigger non-deterministic
exponential time where we also don't
have circuit lower bounds yet okay so
from any even like mild D randomization
of the circuit approximation problem
requires proving some kind of new
circuit lower bound and with with
valentin cabinets we showed that
remember that Poe no Meah identity
testing algorithm that hasn't been doing
random eyes to over 30 years well if you
could do randomized that algorithm even
special cases of that algorithm then you
get algebraic circuit lower bounds
circuit lower bounds that of the same
type that the the algorithm considers
and that's also one of the major getting
arithmetic circuit lower bounds is one
of the major problems in complexity so
so the conclusion is well while we don't
absolutely know whether randomized
algorithms can be do you randomized
there are strange consequences if they
can so I think they really can it's just
a matter of
moving that they really that they can be
D randomized but the way we have to
prove it is by proving circuit lower
bounds or maybe the way we have to prove
circuit lower bounds is by D randomizing
algorithms I haven't quite decided which
one will do first but if you do one you
do the other if you do the other you do
the one so let's just do them both okay
so so it's a challenge because in order
to solve one major problem we have to
solve both major problems but it's also
an opportunity because we know these
interconnections and possibly that can
leverage progress on one into progress
on the other and then that can be a
little bit improved and leverage into
progress on the one and you can like
seesaw until you understand both so
that's my hope
[Applause]
this was the last slide I you know I
could go back and like do some of the
other slower but I got through
everything I met yes
yeah well well I'm talking about the
metropolis algorithm in itself okay so
so let me just explain what I mean so
there's been a lot of work on
understanding so martin metropolis is an
example of Monte Carlo Markov chain
algorithm there's a lot of of not we
have a lot of information about when
Monte Carlo Markov chain algorithms
converged to their stationary
distributions and hence are like
sampling according to the way they were
designed to sample but if you look at
how they're being used they're almost
never being used in context where they
could possibly converge to their
stationary distributions and when the
algorithm and so it's really it turns
out that month
these Monte Carlo Markov chain methods
are really useful even in situations
where we know they're not being useful
for the reasons we understand and so I
think is a really challenging problem to
a really important problem to try to
understand why they're useful when
they're not when they're not when
they're being run for short it's about a
short amount of time and being run maybe
two optimistically and still are being
used to find solutions
Oh
so that's a good that's a that raises a
whole bunch of good questions that would
be like topics for a series of lectures
so the first is where can we get random
bits in nature okay
so your quantum processes are the ones
that we sort of know are probabilistic
but if you're going to look at a model
where we model quantum processes then we
actually go beyond probabilistic
computation in into quantum computation
where probabilities are not just numbers
between zero one but are actually
complex numbers interacting in all sorts
of ways and you can possibly with
quantum machines do things that you
can't do even with this probabilistic
model so the other question is how do we
actually get from natural sources truly
random bits that's the the main subject
of work on extractors which is a very
vibrant area and it's really closely
linked with the kind of pseudo right the
constructions of the pseudo-random
generators that we've been talking about
but how how it's linked is also kind of
complicated did I answer your question
[Music]
yeah so the the skeptical viewpoint is
we don't ever really need a physical
source of randomness you analyzing
algorithms with assuming we had
randomness is just going to be a
stepping stone towards replacing that
randomness with carefully chosen
deterministic steps and so then you
don't have to worry about physics if you
believe that you don't have to worry
about physics or how we're going to get
our source of randomness we're going to
it's just a it's just a part it's just a
stepping stone towards analyzing
inventing and analyzing deterministic
algorithms so it's just a conceptual
tool we imagine randomness for
temporarily and then get rid of it but
if you are not a skeptic then you want
to actually get your hand on randomness
actually I should say even if you are a
skeptic about randomized polynomial time
versus deterministic polynomial time a
randomized algorithm could be linear
time or sub linear time and you can
maybe prove even that if you have a
randomized algorithm sub linear time
your deterministic algorithm has to be
at least linear time so you may still
want to use the randomized algorithm and
if you look at like the deterministic
primary testing versus the randomized
primality testing is still the
deterministic prime ality testing is not
at all practical compared to the
randomized prime ality testing so you
really do want to figure out also figure
out ways of getting your hands on random
bits
so if you can if the function is sort of
defined ahead of time and it's computed
with high probability so it's not it's a
function rather than a relation then you
can like look at it bit by bit and just
talk about bpp if it's a relational
problem that's more complicated and
that's some of the motivation of Shakib
Goldwasser recent work on pseudo
deterministic algorithms
[Applause]